there's a sense of defeat in lachine
armenia will soon lose control over the
strategic district
very few civilians are left in town and
armenian soldiers
are just transiting through on their way
out
bahan kerobian is a businessman turned
volunteer fighter
it's a bittersweet day for him he will
soon meet up with his wife
but ardham the district where he was
deployed at the beginning of the war
is being returned to azerbaijan we were
telling told a lot of
tales about the situation we thought
that our army is so strong
so big because we can do everything but
in reality
i mean no one in the public
knew the real situation we now have
the result that we deserved all of the
armenian forces have to evacuate lachine
before december 1st
a mere 70 kilometers away celebrations
in
akhdam a district on the eastern flank
of the enclave
which armenia occupied and considered a
buffer zone
was among the 60 000 azeri's expelled at
the time from here
i'm lost for words to explain my
feelings it's the best day of my life
the first place i want to visit is the
theater it's destroyed now but it was
very nice and we will rebuild it
a stark contrast to the somber mood and
lachine here too
tens of thousands of azeri's were
expelled
latching was the first district captured
by the armenians in the early
1990s and it will be the last one handed
back to azerbaijan
and it's all because of this road the
so-called latching corridor
that connects armenia to
nagorno-karabakh it will remain
open for armenian civilians and it's the
russian peacekeepers
who are going to guarantee their safe
passage
it's the lifeline of the enclave and is
through this road
that the bulk of the russian
peacekeepers are deploying
and taking up positions along the
corridor azerbaijan's forces
will be just a few kilometers away
it worries araxia marquinhan who stayed
at home throughout the war
she came to the municipality with her
neighbors to ask for help
i don't want to leave here i have a deep
connection my husband and my son are
buried here
i want to be able to visit their grave
and i want to stay
and i want my generation to be moved
again
[Music]
about 12 000 armenians settled in the
lachine district
over the past three decades azerbaijan
said
it would ensure the safety of those
living along the latching corridor
but after all what's happened no one
here is willing to take the risk
but abdul hamid al jazeera lachine